ethan striber is the kind of guy who
would do anything to be an ally he's
about to find out what anything means
this is
social justice
sex tape
that was bj novak doing his best comedic
version of the twilight zone's rod
sterling for his anthology series the
premise on fx and hulu the actor and
comedian is best known for his role as
ryan howard on the hit tv show the
office he spoke to jamie wax about his
career and his full and varied schedule
in the worlds of tv film and publishing
bob vance vance refrigeration ryan
howard bob vance vance refrigeration
what line of work you in bob b.j novak
landed the opportunity of a lifetime
when he was cast in the u.s version of
the office while still in his twenties
who's that nobody
you and i are done what
achieving success and a multi-year gig
as an actor writer and producer
and the story goes it all started with
just one line i learned nothing in
college
it was really kind of my own fault i had
a double major psychology and reverse
psychology
it's rumored that greg daniels
cast you and and hired you as a writer
after the first line of up your opening
line that he saw in fact it was the
pause after that joke he said made him
hire me because he thought well that's
an interesting guy to have in the office
sort of a quiet guy who seems like he's
maybe judging you
which is what he felt i just was trying
to decide what line to say next bj's
gonna be playing the manager of the
restaurant prior to that novak had
achieved success on ashton kutcher's
prank show punk
what
oh nothing
still nothing brought him close to the
fame and acclaim of the office a job
some at the time thought he should turn
down when i got the job offer for the
office nobody thought i should take it
really yes at that time the british
office loomed so large and everyone
thought oh these americans are just
going to screw it up and i remember
reading they're going to ruin it it's
all going to be this terrible laugh
track and i was like oh no and then i
was like wait i was there
there was good there was no laugh track
but you believe what other people are
saying jim the office also randomly
reunited him with an old high school
friend
john krasinski could you guys believe it
when you when you both found out you
were on this project together could you
believe it
i could believe it because the whole
thing was so weird it actually made it
more believable like yeah sure why not
like obviously this is some surreal
dream why wouldn't john from high school
be in the show too
this is dick and bob sherman music and
lyrics the multi-hyphenate has continued
to build a diverse and busy career which
includes roles in major films sound good
yes sir
and even best-selling children's books
what is it about your storytelling that
made you want to want to aim such a
significant part of it at children i
love
um trying to make a kid laugh smile to
me that's the purest form of
of comedy because it's it's really just
love it's just
how do i get the smile of a
five-year-old
the answer is in the title the book with
no pictures it has that great deadpan
sense of humor to introduce kids to
because the book looks like a
tuxedo almost you know it's white and
black and proper looking and it's so
proper looking that i think kids know
there's got to be more to this i'm bj
novak i am so excited to welcome you to
my television show this year he launched
an ambitious and original series on fx
and hulu called the premise a half-hour
anthology of independent stories about
moral questions
there's a running theme of
how much does it cost to the individual
to
to be an agent for change yeah i think
that it's also easy for all of us
in our
daily lives to take the obvious
noble
point of view because it costs us
nothing so in the premiere episode is
really about a guy who says all the
right things online
because
it makes him cooler to his friends what
if he had to do the right thing and it
destroyed
his reputation
or his credibility or his coolness
you know that to me is a funny situation
i look at everything you have done yeah
and everything you are currently doing
it's really amazing to me was that born
into you because you come from a
remarkable family of creators i
recommend my creative process to nobody
it is a terrible creative process i
waste time all day
thinking about everything obsessing
about everything getting very little
done and having no time to myself
but that hasn't stopped him bj novak is
stepping into yet more uncharted
territory writing and directing a
feature film for the first time
vengeance a true crime dark comedy
this is a room where you can obsess over
all of your projects yeah i mean every
part of it i love and hate depending on
how the day is going it's always a ride
so yeah some days i i jump up and take
pictures of the screen and send them to
my friends and think how did i ever you
know become such a genius and then you
know more days than that i look at it
and think i chose the wrong profession
this was just a mistake this whole thing
was a mistake what's different about
directing a feature like this that
you're also acting in and directing
episodics well i found that the more i
take on the more comfortable i am
counter-intuitively it was just
energizing to act it was energizing to
direct so i found that the more i do the
happier i am albuquerque was where we
shot vengeance and that's chaotic as
novak claims his creative process can be
his creativity is far from running dry
did you have any idea you would be
living the creative life you're living
now oh i thought it'd be way bigger than
this i mean i i start everything i do
thinking oh i'm going the distance like
when i did stand up i was like i'm going
to be jerry seinfeld and when i was
directing this movie i'm i'm going to be
tarantino you know and and then it falls
where it does but i always start
everything with a grandiose
vision and then get disappointed where
do you get that from where does that
come from
um i just had the sense of excitement
about everything when i was a kid i
think it's my way of
expressing love if you want a really
deep answer i see something i read once
this quote beauty demands replication
and i feel like the best
way to be as a creative person is to see
something and love it so much that you
want to do your version of it for cbs
saturday morning jamie wax
los
angeles i recommend my creative process
to no one
i get nothing done and then and then he
gets everything done working for him
that's a great mind right there no